- So, right here, we have the number 46,
we have a four in the tens place,
so it literally represents four tens,
and we see them here, one,
two, three, four tens.
That's a ten, that's a ten,
that's a ten, and that's a ten.
Each of these are ten squares,
so all together we have four
tens or 40 squares in purple
and then we have a six in the ones place.
We have a six in the ones
place, we have six ones,
and we see that right over
here, one, two, three, four,
five, six, so we can write
that 46, use the same colors,
46 is equal to four tens, four tens
and six ones, or I could
write plus six ones.
Now, let's do something interesting.
Let's subtract, let's subtract
four ones from the 46,
so, let's think about
what it means to take,
let's take 46, so I'm
going to start with 46,
just the number that
we have in front of us,
and we are going to subtract four.
We are going to subtract four.
What is this going to be
equal to, how many tens?
So it's going to be a
certain number of tens,
and it's going to be plus
a certain number of ones,
plus a certain number of ones,
so I've left blanks right over here,
so how many tens are we going to have?
So, 46, that's what we started with,
we're subtracting four ones,
so we're going to subtract
one, two, three, four, we're
going to take away four ones.
So how many tens do we have?
Well, we still have four tens,
so let's write that down,
we still have four tens, but
now how many ones do we have?
Well, now we only have two
ones, we only have two ones,
and so you see when you
have four tens and six ones
and you subtracted four ones,
well, six ones minus four ones
is two ones, and so we
get 46, let me do that
in the same color, we get
40, I'm having issues here,
(laughs) So, it's going
to be, this is going to be
46 minus four is equal to four tens,
well that's just a four in the tens place,
so write a four in the tens place,
and then two ones, put a
two in the ones place, 42.
46 minus four is 42, and
you can see that right there
in the ones place, we just
took four from this six.